suppose you placed a camera at a fixed
position took a picture of the sky at
the same time every day for an entire
year and overlaid all of the photos on
top of each other what would the Sun
look like in that combined image a
stationary dot a circular path
neither oddly enough it makes this
figure 8 pattern known as the sun's
analemma but why the Earth's movement
creates a few cycles first of all it
rotates on its axis about once every 24
hours producing sunrises and sunsets at
the same time it's making a much slower
cycle orbiting around the Sun
approximately every 365 days but there's
a twist relative to the plane of its
orbit the earth doesn't spin with the
North Pole pointing straight up instead
its axis has a constant tilt of 23.4
degrees this is known as the Earth's
axial tilt or obliquity a 23 degree tilt
may not seem important but it's the main
reason that we experience different
seasons because the axis remains tilted
in the same direction while the earth
makes its annual orbit there are long
periods each year when the northern half
of the planet remains tilted toward the
Sun while the southern half is tilted
away and vice-versa what we experience
as summer and winter during summer in a
given hemisphere the Sun appears higher
in the sky making the days longer and
warmer once a year the sun's declination
the angle between the equator and the
position on the earth where the Sun
appears directly overhead reaches its
maximum this day is known as the summer
solstice the longest day of the year and
the one day where the Sun appears
highest in the sky so the Earth's axial
tilt partially explains why the Sun
changes positions in
and the an ulemas length represents the
full forty six point eight degrees of
the sun's declination throughout the
year but why is it a figure eight and
not just a straight line this is due to
another feature of the Earth's
revolution it's orbital eccentricity the
Earth's orbit around the Sun is an
ellipse with its distance to the Sun
changing at various points the
corresponding change in gravitational
force causes the earth to move fastest
in January when it reaches its closest
point to the Sun the perihelion and the
slowest in July when it reaches its
farthest point the aphelion the Earth's
eccentricity means that solar noon the
time when the Sun is highest in the sky
doesn't always occur at the same point
in the day so a sundial may be as much
as 16 minutes ahead or 14 minutes behind
a regular clock in fact clock time and
Sun time only match four times a year
the analemma x' width represents the
extent of this deviation so how did
people know the correct time years ago
for most of human history going by the
sun's position was close enough but
during the modern era the difference
between Sun dials and mechanical clocks
became important the equation of time
introduced by Ptolemy and later refined
based on the work of Johann Kepler
converts between apparent solar time and
the mean time we've all come to rely on
globes even used to have the analemma
printed on them to allow people to
determine the difference between clock
time and solar time based on the day of
the year just how the analemma appears
depends upon where you are it'll be
tilted at an angle depending on your
latitude
or inverted if you're in the southern
hemisphere and if you're on another
planet you might find something
completely different depending on that
planets orbital eccentricity and axial
tilt the analemma might appear as a
teardrop oval or even a straight line